e voi avete mai letto il primo deve
morire in qualche modo deve morire e si
sono prima il tigre novellos dias a
todos e mi venite in questo nuovo video
di slide slither la farò prima o poi
farà entro giusta al primo tentativo ce
la farò blocco lo metto al ragazzo ho
trovato un nuovo modo figo di scrivere
fa vj che questo anzi ecco più
accentuato di così è impossibile
niente ragazzi siamo con la scalata al
successo che minchia neanche al
milionario era così difficile arrivare
in top classifica però ci proviamo anche
oggi tanto so che farò cagare comunque a
che è bello il nostro appuntamento sul
gioco che mi farà lanciare la tastiera
anche oggi sempre contenta la mia
tastiera quando gioca sta roba ce la
vedo tutta frizzante che non vede l'ora
che ci giochi sono riusciti nella mente
[Musica]
in culo è bravo oddio cosa ho fatto
cosa ho fatto i culi i culi che square
prof rogo ho trovato il portatore
dell'anello che sta ottavo in posizione
lo uccido
e vabbè mica quante grosso non è stato
così difficile neanche le signore degli
anelli uccidere frode ragazzi ma lui c'è
l'anello non può morire è cosa vuole
questo demolisce la dinastia fatto solo
io e te la devi solo giocare da solo
guarda ma dove va beh questo è il primo
regga il primo papa tunde e tu ne vada
tonde tonde e papà tunde ma non uccido
io se lo uccido entrò di diritto in top
ten per forza dio mio sapevo io e morto
è morto il primo è morto primo ottobre
scorso la troppa forti io non ho fatto
un cazzo proprio i punti
no no no no no ok ok ok pian piano
tranquilli tranquilli gli ho potuto
quasi tutti i punti lega sono xi fa vj
decimo già passato decimo subito cazzo
ciao zio
il mio è più lungo cioè il cuore che
batte a mille ogni volta che riunì
classifica non riesco più a contenermi
prove
vai al sodo ma perché non sto facendo un
cazzo pro scalo alla classifica
qualcuno ho fatto tutti quanti e vabbé
vabbé vabbé vabbé calmi calmi tutti i
capi tutti vii vii vii settimana poi vi
ho superato prove di gala nella lontano
da zia l'ultima volta che sono stato
così in pensione per un videogioco è
stato qualche ok è stato quando ho
tirato per la prima volta la carica
nucleare sul mondo air warfare 2
ma tipo 45 anni fa era da allora che non
provavo un andrenalina così potente per
un gioco stupido eccolo lì però sono
terzo dai cazzo approdo ma superato a
chi bastardo amare non ti tocco l'anello
la torta cosa sta facendo cosa ha fatto
come mi sono salvato musica si stanno
dando battaglia ma si stava tornando
verso l'alto come cazzo siete tornati to
spiegamelo no voglio capire
moto come mi sono salvato lei e quanta
gente crepa tutti i morti sono parte io
sono forte fortissimo che sarò ma non mi
succede quando sono primo cioè quando
sono quasi primo da in un secondo non
preso un miliardo e mezzo la vera mi
chiama ecco un'altra botta così però non
subito cioè dammi tempo di reagire e va
bene va bene quanta gente morta amorim
or die verde che eccolo lo aspettavo io
[Musica]
vai vai va tutti in culo dovete andare
madonna street caccia ci fai
ma non c'entrava niente quel cristiano
lì è rispuntato a caso del viola se cosa
vuoi fare tu brutto deficiente è appunto
knox no perché si è aperta un'altra
pagina ogni tanto mi si aprono le pagine
va bene allora ok
[Musica]
la foto cosa ucciso bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye perfetto
che la madonna costo facendo boom tutti
i morti che di morti vabbè primo vinto
così a caso cioè dai merito il primo
posto solo prestazione ragazzi che cosa
ho fatto una donna tutti morti tutti
morti
casino di fatto tutti i punti non sarà
che chi è stato a uccidere chi prof
io ho fatto tutto mai dokic ora quello
guarda quello di rimessa e va certo io
sono forte nuovi tool è infatti è morto
a mio comando proprio el'amato
docente quanta gente di casino quinto
dai prova ad arginarli tutti se riesco
ce lo fa madonna che azione per azione
pari j
grazie una morto dai morire tumori bordo
lo ha ripetuto efficiente eccolo lì
preparato sono terzo di nuovo dai guarda
questo sarà il primo a niente
a 18.000 sto per perdermi odio
oddio dio mio dio mio dio mio dio mio
come mai il primo deve morire in qualche
modo da morire
se sono qui ma la cig renault sono
braves l'ater in slitta come cazzo si
dice ancora non ho capito che adesso
tutta la passerà sotto casa mia a farmi
i complimenti mi hanno già superato
bastare una vita e mezza per arrivare
primo dio mio che odio per questo
videogame che bello fa vj primo questi
sono i veri traguardi della vita fotte
sega di tutto il resto sono arrivato
primo su slitte rio ma che cazzo volete
devo chiamare mia madre dopo questa cosa
io devo dire assolutamente ancora più
primo sono più primo di prima
e vabbè ma wright e so se con com'è
possibile ho preso miliardo di punti sul
secondo
ora ecco scusa mena e capiamo
l'importanza e personale l'obiettivo più
grande sarà battere il mio record che in
questo momento è di 19 mila e qualcosa
quindi se riesco a fare 20.000 punti
sono un figlio e mi sono arrivato
presente primo che non solo ogni tanto
mi sorpassa andava bene normale non c'è
più quell istinto di voler uccidere
gente tipo sto
perché tanto non mi intendo sono grosso
l'importante è aver cielo grosso poi
chissenefrega tanto sono diventato primo
con una skin che fa veramente schifo se
invece questi mi fa veramente cagare non
so perché l'ho scelta è scemo chi legge
sa mica come sei bullo guarda come sono
più bullo di te
che sono una persona forte io uccido i
più piccoli ma che cazzo se frega che
narrano quello sono vivo per miracolo
sono io per mia ora che mi stava
ammazzando lui non l'avevo visto era
talmente piccolo che non l'avevo visto e
va bene va bene va bene quanta gente
quanta gente che palle non mai curato
quasi luca ti ho chiuso come come passa
dai ma come ha fatto l'ha fatta a
passare da lì minchia vitasnella
resistendo la nora e mezzo aveva partita
più lunga di svizzeri peperino mandarino
bello non letti di nicknames traina mi
come ho fatto a sbatterci contro come
casa guardando il microfono che sta
accadendo giù a furia di tirare pugni
sulla scrivania e mentre guardavo il
mico distratto un secondo niente ma
banco fuga non sono incazzato per una
volta i raid con la forza di peter siamo
riusciti arrivare primi va bene così
ragazzi va bene sono contento non me ne
frega niente vediamo mi abbia registrato
tutto se non potrei lanciare più
microfoni dal balcone alla volta spero
che vi sia per cento ragazzi un'acqua
allora quale like e la condivisione su
facebook voglio tutto voglio che lo
faccia te delata alla mamma stovini nota
a chiunque la supremazia di slither in
questo video spero che video vi sia
piaciuto sono contento di aver raggiunto
questo traguardo nella mia vita che per
me è importante come sento ragazzi
servito piaciuta sull'argomento è un mi
piace ai capace di facebook e con il
video tra descrizione del city se noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video belle ragazze